[Musica]
non mi è mai piaciuto volare e so per
certo di non esser l'unico circa sei
persone su dieci provano una sensazione
che va da un leggero disagio a un
profondo terrore quando devono prendere
un volo aereo non è mai piaciuto volare
ed è un problema perché al contrario
amo profondamente viaggiare viaggiare è
stato un desiderio fortissimo per me nel
corso della mia vita anche solo la
prospettiva di poter partire per andare
a esplorare nuovi orizzonti nuove
culture nuovi sapori nuove persone è
sempre stato qualcosa che mi
entusiasmava che mi rendeva felice
nonostante questa passione viscerale per
il viaggio che mi ha portato poi a fare
di tutto per poter lavorare viaggiando e
quindi poter viaggiare il più possibile
non ho mai amato volare anzi sono una di
quelle persone che quando si trovava su
un volere un po problematico con una
turbolenza si terrorizzava ed era questo
più o meno il pensiero che avevo in
mente alcuni anni fa su un volo che da
un kong mi stava riportando a bali che
il posto che io chiamo casa per alcuni
mesi dell'anno il volo stava andando
alla perfezione quando a un certo punto
la prima scossa quella sensazione che
tutti noi conosciamo si accendono le
luci del della cintura allacciata il
segnale della cintura allacciata il
comandante ordina a tutti di tornare
immediatamente al proprio posto perché
siamo appena entrati in una fase con
forti turbolenze
io non ero seduto ovviamente però sul
fondo dell'aereo è andato a chiedere un
bicchiere d'acqua
quando un certo punto tutto si mise a
tremare è il mio istinto fu quello di
girarmi e di andare immediatamente al
mio posto
ma mentre stavo per fare questo
movimento qualcosa cattura la mia
attenzione
c'era un hostess sul fondo dell'aereo
che stava sistemando gli snack sul
carrello e sembrava la persona più
tranquilla del mondo sembrava essere
totalmente in pace con se stessa
completamente disinteressata a quella
turbolenza che invece stava
terrorizzando me è la maggior parte dei
passeggeri
per me era inconcepibile
non riuscivo a spiegarmi come riuscisse
a essere così calma così tranquilla come
riuscisse a continuare a fare il suo
lavoro come se nulla fosse così
approfittando di un momento in cui
l'aereo non vibrava particolarmente
decisi di andare a chiederglielo mi
lanciai mi avvicinai feci un sorriso per
celare il disagio e l'imbarazzo e le
chiesi semplicemente come fai a non
avere paura e vedete il bello di
viaggiare e che ci sono dei momenti
apparentemente insignificanti per gli
altri che invece hanno la potenzialità
di cambiarti la vita e quello fu uno di
quei momenti perché lo stesso giro mi
studio per un attimo un po confusa per
quella domanda sicuramente inaspettata
proprio mi rispose senza esitazioni e mi
disse gli aeroplani sono fatti per
volare quelle parole nella loro
semplicità iniziano a risuonare dentro
di mandare andranno a toccare delle
corde che avevo dentro e che neanche
sapevo di avere le mie idee un po
confuso e ripreso a parlare mi disse lo
sai che ci sono molte più possibilità
che un aeroplano causi un incidente
quando e per terra
rispetto a quando in volo perché gli
aeroplani sono dei mezzi estremamente
pesanti sono ingombranti sono difficili
da manovrare per terra gli aeroplani
sono stati progettati e studiati per
stare in cielo il cielo e la loro
dimensione quindi quando un aeroplano in
cielo non è nulla di cui preoccuparsi
gli aeroplani sono fatti per volare e
con quell'ultima frase fece un sorriso
mi indicò il segnale delle cinture
allacciate e mi congedo io tornai subito
al mio posto e avevo tutte queste parole
che mi risuonavano dentro deciso di fare
una cosa che non avevo mai fatto
guardare fuori dal finestrino
non l'avevo mai fatto perché pensavo che
rendermi conto dell'altezza a cui
viaggiava della velocità a cui stava
andando l'aereo avrebbe terrorizzato
guardai fuori e non vi di niente non
c'era niente perché era notte fonda
quindi vedeva malapena l'ala dell'aereo
eppure non avevo nessuna paura nessuna
paura mi sentivo tranquillo e per
assurdo mi sentivo per la prima volta
nella mia vita al sicuro su un aereo da
quel giorno non ho mai più avuto paura
di volare
ma non è questa la cosa più importante
che è successo a bordo di quel volo
perché quelle parole semplici ma in un
certo senso illuminanti di quello stairs
quella strana conversazione che ho avuto
con lei ha dato il via un effetto domino
dentro di me e di riflessioni che mi
portarono a una riflessione finale gli
aeroplani sono fatti per volare su
questo non c'è dubbio
e noi esseri umani invece per quello
siamo fatti qual è la nostra dimensione
come il cielo lo è per l'aeroplano che
cosa possiamo fare ogni singolo giorno
per poter essere felici per sentirci
realizzati
io ho cercato a lungo una risposta a
questa domanda mi è rimasto proprio
dentro questa grande a questa serie di
domande e l'ho cercata fuori la risposta
ho cercata confrontandomi con altre
culture con altri modi di intendere la
vita
leggendo tanti libri guardando tanti
film poi un giorno mi sono reso conto
che la risposta ce l'avevo dentro
dovevo semplicemente riavvolgere il
nastro e andare a rivedere tutte le
esperienze che avevo vissuto in giro per
il mondo tutti gli stati d'animo cavour
che avevo avuto ero sicuro che facendo
questo processo avrei trovato la
risposta è così parti da quando ero un
ragazzo appena uscito dal liceo che era
convinto che la forma della sua felicità
fosse quella più tradizionale quella che
gli era stata insegnata fin da piccolo
quindi laureati prendi magari una
seconda laurea trova un bel lavoro
prestigioso inizia a lavorare duramente
per poi potersi permettere una casa
magari una casa in centro da ostentare
agli amici e avere un'automobile potente
con cui girare la domenica mattina per
farti vedere dagli altri e suscitare un
po di invidia
credo fosse quella la forma della mia
felicità
e così aveva iniziato questo percorso mi
ha iscritto all'università pensando di
fare il primo passo in quella direzione
poi però mi resi conto dopo pochi mesi
che non sarei mai riuscito a trovare la
felicità in quel modo perché anche solo
pensare a quella vita mi rendeva
infelice e non perché sia sbagliato ma
perché per me non poteva funzionare la
forma della mia felicità non poteva
essere quella così decisi a vent'anni di
lasciare l'università prendere tutti i
pochi risparmi che avevo e comprare un
biglietto di sola andata per l'australia
con l'intenzione di arrivare la cercare
immediatamente lavoro per poter
sopravvivere ma soprattutto esplorare
gli stili di vita alternativi lepida
alternative
cercare delle risposte e così iniziò il
mio girare per il mondo che adesso dura
da più di otto anni
ma quello che è stato veramente
importante del mio girovagare sono stati
gli incontri che ho fatto in australia
ad esempio che uno abbia un ragazzo
italiano che si era trasferito gli
alcuni anni prima e che faceva
l'istruttore di surf lui si alza ogni
mattina all'alba prendeva la sua tavola
percorreva a piedi e le poche centinaia
di metri che lo separavano dall'oceano
si buttava nel mare con un entusiasmo
che non avevo mai visto nella mia vita e
quando era tra le onde
era la persona più felice del mondo ecco
se a lui e l'avessero chiesto se gli
avessero chiesto per cosa si è fatto
gli avrebbe risposto senza esitazioni
sono fatto per far surf se poteva
svegliarsi ogni mattina fare surf era
felice indipendentemente da ciò che
accadeva andare su e la sua giornata
qualche anno più tardi mi trasferì in
canada e lì conobbi un personaggio
veramente curioso un uomo di 70 anni che
aveva lavorato per trent'anni in una
banca canadese una grossa banca canadese
anche con un impiego di una certa
responsabilità e prestigio
poi un giorno sia stufato non era felice
di quella vita va deciso di licenziarsi
prenderla liquidazione investirla per
fare il giro del mondo e così aveva
fatto aveva iniziato a girare tutto il
mondo visitando decine di paesi
immergendosi in tantissimi modi di
vivere diversi tantissime culture
diverse e aveva capito alla fine che non
c'era nessun posto migliore di quello
che lui da sempre chiamava caso
vancouver era il posto più bello del
mondo per lui allora era tornato a
vancouver ma questa volta non più per
lavorare in banca per fare ciò che lo
rendeva felice aveva comprato un terreno
era iniziato a coltivare i mirtilli e
quando lui me lo raccontò questo fatto
io rimasi un attimo confusi di fi
mirtilli e perché i mirtilli
dopo tutto quello che hai fatto i viaggi
la banca e lui mi rispose semplicemente
per me i mirtilli sono la felicità
poterli coltivare poterli prendere
poterne fare delle marmellate dei
biscotti e il mio risotto che il risotto
più buono di tutto il canada
sottolineava sempre mi rende felice più
recentemente invece un paio di anni fa
ho incontrato una ragazza balli che mi
ha raccontato la sua storia anche lei si
era trasferita a vivere
ma a sostare era veramente particolare
era arrivata sull'isola come tanti altri
turisti per visitarla
poi una volta lì però si era innamorata
di quel luogo e un giorno mentre guidava
il suo scooter si rese conto di quanti
cani randagi ci fossero in giro questa
consapevole che questa consapevolezza la
colpì con tale forza che lei decise di
rimanere a balli vivere a bandi ma per
prendersi cura dei cani randagi
così iniziò a lavorare come volontari in
un ambulatorio poi ne aprì uno suo
e adesso questa è la sua vita una vita
estremamente più dura difficile sporca
rispetto a quella che aveva molto più
semplice in occidente ma una vita piena
una vita che la rende felice
e se trovi la tua felicità in fondo non
hai bisogno di nient'altro ecco io noi
conosciuta decine di persone così con
una forma della loro felicità veramente
alternativa è strano e ripensando a loro
mi sono reso conto che non possiamo
rispondere alla domanda percorso siamo
fatti perché noi esseri umani siamo
molto più complicati di un aeroplano
se tu chiedi una persona che cosa che
forma la tua felicità ogni singola
persona ti dà una risposta diversa
oppure ancora più grave ti risponde non
lo so quindi la vera domanda non è
questa perché c'è un comun denominatore
tra tutte le persone felici che ha
incontrato ed è il fatto che erano tutte
riuscite a valorizzare il loro tempo
avete presente quella sensazione che
sono sicuro che molti di voi hanno
provato almeno una volta nella vita di
arrivare magari in ufficio arrivare sul
posto di lavoro guardare l'orologio
vedere che sono le nove e un quarto è
dire da nazioni cosa non darei per poter
far volare le prossime autore per
poterle consumare teletrasportarvi a
stasera quando sarò libero di fare
quello che voglio io questa sensazione
la provo proprio all'università era
davvero una situazione che non mi non mi
rendeva felice mi sentivo come un
animale in gabbia gli e quindi arrivavo
in aula e dicevo quanto vorrei poter
consumare in fretta queste ore
ecco nessuna delle persone felici che ho
incontrato sul mio percorso aveva questi
pensieri ma dire la verità nessuno di
loro neanche si chiedeva che cos'è la
felicità semplicemente lo erano
perché erano riusciti a riempire il loro
tempo di ciò che gli piace fare allora
alla domanda cosa possiamo fare ogni
singolo giorno x
ora il nostro tempo ho trovato delle
risposte in questo caso ho ripensato il
mio percorso e queste sono le tre fasi
per valorizzare il proprio tempo quelle
che funzionano per me ma potrebbero
benissimo funzionare anche per voi
la prima fase è trovare il proprio i
kings ai big eye è un termine giapponese
che significa ragion d'essere e lo scopo
della vita di una persona è il motivo
per cui al mattino ti alzi e vivi la
maggior parte delle persone non sa
rispondere alla domanda quale i tuoi ti
guy chi invece riesce a rispondere a
questa domanda non solo ha valorizzato
il proprio tempo ma probabilmente anche
trovato la felicità perché secondo i
giapponesi litigai e l'intersezione di
quattro aspetti ciò che ami fare ciò che
sai fare ciò che puoi condividere con
gli altri magari per fare del bene agli
altri e ciò che puoi fare per mantenerti
per pagare le bollette per poterti
mantenere per l'appunto il punto più
importante forse l'ultimo riuscire a
fare dell'iti guy un lavoro perché io
stesso come dicevo desideravo che il
tempo passa in fretta ma dal momento in
cui sono riuscito a fare della mia
passione per la scrittura un lavoro del
viaggio che era un'altra mia grande
passione uno stile di vita ed al momento
in cui iniziato a verde gli obiettivi in
cui credo fortemente
ho smesso di desiderare che il tempo
passa in fretta anzi io mi sveglio al
mattino e vorrei che le giornate
passassero lentamente vorrei non
sprecare neanche uno
e allora trovare il proprio chi gay è
fondamentale per riuscire a valorizzare
il proprio tempo e come si trova litigai
credo che ci sono tanti modi ma uno dei
più efficaci e tornare indietro con la
testa con la mente ma quando si era
giovanni a quando si era un adolescente
che adulto sognavi di diventare quali
erano i tuoi sogni e non è importante se
alla fine non sei riuscito a diventare
il chitarrista di una band famoso in
tutto il mondo perché quando sei giovani
se anche un po infantile ovviamente ma
se la musica era la tua più grande
passione era ciò che più ti accendeva e
se finito a digitare cifre davanti allo
schermo di un computer per otto ore al
giorno rinchiuso dentro quattro pareti
allora qualcosa è andato storto
se il tuo sogno era di diventare una
veterinaria a occuparti ogni giorno
degli animali
ti sei laureata in giurisprudenza per
far contenta tua madre qualcosa è andato
storto
queste situazioni non solo creano una
grande insoddisfazione personale ma
anche un sentimento di odio invidia
perché tu non fai quello che ti piace e
sai che c'è qualcuno là fuori che lo sta
facendo magari perché avuto più coraggio
di te magari avuto più fortuna ma
comunque c'è qualcuno là fuori che lo
sta facendo questo a lungo andare ti
logora ti rovina la vita
il secondo la seconda fase per trotter
riuscire a valorizzare il proprio tempo
e essere viaggiatori e essere
viaggiatori significa ovviamente
viaggiare nel mondo è un consiglio che
do chiunque investire i propri soldi nei
viaggi significa dar valore al proprio
tempo aggiungere vita alla vita
d'altronde capita spesso di passare
intere settimane a casa di cui non si ha
nessun ricordo poi partì per un viaggio
di ogni singola giornata ricordi tutto
ai vari ricordi questo credo sia una
delle definizioni più belle del
valorizzare il proprio tempo ricordarmi
se non te la ricordi non puoi dire di
averla vissuta fino in fondo la vita
ma il vero il vero senso dell'essere
viaggiatori non è collezionare timbri
sul passaporto è una questione di
mentalità
qual è il contrario di viaggiare il
contrario di viaggiare stare fermi
stare fermi che vuol dire stare fermi
fisicamente ma anche star fermi sulle
proprie posizioni rinchiudersi nelle
proprie abitudini in ciò che conosciamo
non rischiare mai non andare mai
esplorare l'ignoto e allora essere
viaggiatori è una questione di stile di
vita di approccio alla vita
faccio un esempio se ogni mattina vedi
una ragazza che magari ti piace e la
osservi però poi non riesci mai a fare
quel passo per andare a parlarle
ecco buttati parti viaggia dentro di lei
viaggio dentro i suoi sogni dentro suo
modo di vedere la vita nel suo passato
nei suoi progetti le sue ambizioni
buttati questo vuol dire esser
viaggiatori
hai un brutto rapporto con tuo padre e
non ne parlate mai però avete col muro
di indifferenza tra di voi
iniziate un viaggio insieme fate quella
conversazione che rimandate da troppi
anni
questo significa esser viaggiatori vuol
dire smettere di essere passeggeri e
invece diventare piloti della propria
vita prenderne il controllo questo
significa esser viaggiatori e il terzo
punto per imparare a valorizzare il
proprio tempo e quello che forse gli sta
un po più a cuore
essere artigiani del proprio tempo nel
corso del mio girare per il mondo svolto
decine e decine di lavori diversi tra
cui quello del panificatore mi svegliavo
ogni notte quando tutti dormivano
iniziamo a lavorare e prendevo a dormire
mentre tutti erano al lavoro e una vita
molto dura una vita non semplice però il
lavoro del panificatore dal ha la grande
possibilità di pensare di riflettere tu
sei lì che impasti intanto con la mente
ragioni rifletti e fai delle scoperte
che ti possono cambiare la vita in quel
periodo io ne feci una e cioè che il mio
pane a quello che facevo io per me era
il più buono del mondo e attenzione non
perché io sia il miglior panificatore
del mondo assolutamente ma perché era
mio era mio lo avevo scelto io quel pane
lo avevo modellato come volevo io gli
avevo messo gli ingredienti che più mi
piacevano lo avevo cotto come piaceva a
lei abbordato la forma che volevo io era
fatto esattamente sulla forma del mio
gusto e credo che questa sia un'ottima
metafora di ciò che significa
valorizzare il proprio tempo il tempo lo
dovete modellare dovete essere degli
artigiani del vostro tempo non dei
consumatori non potete trovarlo
preconfezionato sullo scaffale del
supermercato come avviene invece con il
pane il vostro tempo lo dovreste
modellare sulla forma della vostra
felicità qualunque essa sia
questo è fondamentale e per riuscire a
essere artigiani del proprio tempo
c'è un modo che mi ha trasmesso un
monaco buddista alcuni anni fa ho avuto
la
l'onore e il privilegio di parlare con
un anziano monaco buddista chang mai in
thailandia il quale al quale poi una
domanda provocatoria gli chiesi c'è un
modo per essere felici
ogni singolo giorno e lui mi disse la
felicità per come la intendete voi
occidentali è una questione di imparare
a vivere nel momento presente perché voi
occidentali siete ossessionati dal
passato e dal futuro ma il passato non
torna e quindi non ha alcun effetto su
di voi
quindi non esiste il passato il futuro
non è altro che un ipotesi questo tipo
utilizzando di averlo un futuro ma non è
detto quindi non dovreste neanche
pensarci per vivere ogni singola
giornata come se fosse un nuovo inizio
come se fosse una nuova vita
e se ci riuscite riuscite a darvi la
possibilità di essere felici ogni
singolo giorno perché ogni giorno è un
nuovo inizio
si parte tutto da capo
io ho cercato di fare mia questa
filosofia di vita è la prima cosa che ho
fatto è stato smettere di essere schiavo
del calendario è una cosa a cui ho
pensato soltanto negli ultimi anni e mi
son reso conto di quanto siamo davvero
schiavi delle date sul calendario c'è
c'è una data che ci dice quando possiamo
essere felici c'è una data che invece
rappresenta un giorno qualsiasi a nonna
anonimo che non vale niente
c'è una data magari in cui invece non
ammessi al tristi perché torniamo dalle
ferie giorno a lavorare e il punto è che
riuscire a capire che ogni singola
giornata è un nuovo inizio è davvero un
passo importantissimo verso la propria
felicità perché la vedete questa foto
io non l'ho scattata il giorno di natale
non l'ho scattata il giorno del mio
compleanno non era sabato sera quel
momento in cui ti senti costretto essere
felice
io non so nemmeno quando è stata
scattata questa foto però ricordo che
ero su un'isola thailandese che si
chiama colite e ricordo che questa
giornata è stata una delle più felici
della mia vita
questa è l'unica cosa che conta pertanto
l'augurio che io faccio a chiunque
incontri sulla mia strada e quello che
c'è scritto sul mio sul mio taccuino di
viaggio è la nightlife trovate il vostri
ti guy siate viaggiatori della vita
gli artigiani del vostro tempo e
riuscirete a ottenere esattamente questo
una buona vita grazie
[Applauso]